Speaker 1: Let's get right to the mailbag. The
last mailbag before the 2022 midterms. You can
email info at David Pakman dot com sometimes
will highlight a YouTube comment or a Twitter
message or Facebook message. It really could
be anything, but it's mostly email and the
email address is info at David Pakman dot com.
Let's start today with a message from Fred. No,
this is the wrong one. That's for later. Here
is the one I wanted to start with. David. Dear
Mr. Pacman, they say I was attempting to listen
on YouTube to the Fetterman Oz debate. However,
your constant comments and biased interjections
and opinions are extremely troubling. Are they
really troubling? I should be careful. Are you
wanting to convince your listeners to follow
your to follow your partizan views? I'm not sure
how you can be a leader of a show in this capacity
and expect to be successful as a reporter. You
should be more balanced and especially not give
your comments. This is another right winger who
doesn't have a clue what's going on. I am not
a reporter. This is a commentary show. This show
can only be successful if I give my opinion. Now,
am I trying to convince people? Whatever. I'm
just giving my opinions. It's not troubling that
an opinion person gives opinions. And in fact,
it's not about expect to be successful. We've got
nearly 2 million subscribers across all of our
platforms, actually, more like 2.3, 2.2 million
across all of our platforms. So there are
people who are furious when I give my opinion,
but that's what the show is. And again, it's that
lack of media literacy. There is no news show
here. This is an opinion show. It's an opinion
podcast where I give my opinion. I got another
email about the debate coverage and we've been
getting a lot of these because what happens is.
People look for the debate. And sometimes when
you type in, you know, as Fetterman debate,
our livestream can come up in the first few
results on YouTube. And so people who have
no clue about our show will just click over to
it and then they stumble across me. And here I
am making comments. How dare I? And so people get
confused and they write in and they prefer me to
just sit there silently, not saying anything. Joe
West, who misspelled his own name after listening
and watching you on side screen. It is very will
seen that you are a Democrat. I believe what this
I believe this is Joseph. And what Joseph
is trying to say is that after watching me
on the side of the screen alongside the debate,
it became obvious to him that I am a Democrat.
Now I know I'm correcting six or seven different
things there to come up with that interpretation,
but I feel like it's probably accurate. I am
not a Democrat and if you want someone who
just says nothing during the debates, there are
endless other free streams that you can find.
Speaker 2: One more.
Speaker 1: And this is an actually interesting and
productive comment about the debates. Twitchell
says, why is it after a debate where the Democrat
destroys the Republican? Nothing changes with
polling. But if a Democrat doesn't do well,
the polls tip towards the Republican. It would
seem swing voters would be the reason. But why
are Democrats held to a higher standard? This is
absolutely the case. And I know that there are so
many right wingers who will reject the notion that
Democrats hold candidates to a higher standard
than Republicans. It is undeniably true in every
way. Let's talk through it. Donald Trump could
never have been the Democratic nominee. Democrats
would not have accepted an obvious con man grifter
from the business world who isn't even
particularly good at business. But he was
just given a great head start with a small loan
of $1,000,000 and much more help with his debt.
Democrats never would have accepted Trump as a
nominee because their standards are higher. I'm
not a Democrat, but I'm just telling you that
that's the reality. The only electorate that
would be so low information and bamboozle a bull
that Trump could trick them into nominating him
is the Republican Party because their standards
are significantly lower. Their standards are. Do
you claim to be against abortion even when you're
obviously not? And Trump did that. Do you claim to
be religious even when you're obviously not?
Trump did it. Okay. Can you attack the right
people to make us wait a mexican rapist and all
this stuff? Trump did those things. The standards
are way lower. I have to tell you, it's similar
to a fault even with like the sexual assault stuff
where Republicans will often defend their own when
they are accused of sexual assault and misconduct
endlessly. Whereas, if anything, Democrats are
too quick to condemn. Remember the Al Franken
situation? What Al Franken? The tasteless joke
that Al Franken participated in was absolutely in
poor taste, but immediate demands for Al Franken
to resign, which he did. Democrats arguably went
too far because their standards are so much
higher than those of Republicans. So that's
why the debates matter in the way that Twitchell
is saying. Astute observation, Allen wrote in.
This depresses me. Okay. I have this really
depressed. Woody Allen wrote it and said,
you say you want subscribers. You say it's free.
There is no way to subscribe without paying.
What kind of scam are you running?
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen.
As I've said before, it is free to
subscribe to our YouTube channel.
We have. Over a million and a half YouTube
subscribers. As much as it would be amazing
to have a million and a half paid subscribers,
we don't. It is free to subscribe on YouTube.
It is free to subscribe on YouTube.
You just hit subscribe. It's free.
I've said subscribe to the podcast. It is free to
subscribe to the podcast. We produce it every day,
every weekday. It is free, it's on iTunes,
Spotify, etc., etc.. The one thing that you
pay for is to become a website member. Yes, you do
pay for that. But folks, I'm not scamming anybody.
It's really free to subscribe on YouTube. It is
really free to subscribe to the podcast. It's
free to like us on Facebook to follow on
Twitch. All of those things are free. But
to become a website member, you do pay. All
right. Please, please, please. Let's be clear.
I can't tell whether this email is serious, but
it seemed like it was. As I mentioned last week,
we are working on a white paper with techniques
for how to talk about politics with people in
your family, your coworkers, whatever. The
term white paper is a typical well-known term.
I got an email from someone saying my opinion,
but I would never call a document a white paper.
It sounds very KKK ish. I do love your show.
But besides this mistake, I hope. I hope, yes,
I'm deliberately using a racist term white paper,
folks. I don't know if this is serious. A white
paper is a completely established and well-known
term. It's an informational document that a
company uses to highlight something, to highlight
research about an issue or to highlight a product
or a service or a market opportunity or whatever.
It's it's a completely benign, banal term. It's
it's a white paper. I don't know if this viewer
genuinely thinks that it might be a racist term.
I just got to move on, folks. I can't I can't
even deal with it. It's just a white paper.
Raymond wrote in about my interview with former
Scientologist Mike Rinder. Now, Raymond is a
Scientologist. It might not shock you to hear that
Raymond isn't happy with my Mike Rinder interview.
Raymond wrote in. David, I watch your
channel for info on recent political events,
but your recent interview with Mike Rinder
is one sided. You have someone who's trying
to make money on his experiences with
Scientology. I don't see you trying
to get to the other side of the coin and
interview an executive from Scientology. Or,
better yet, why don't you pay a visit
to a Church of Scientology? So, listen,
I know Scientology executives are going to come
on the show. First of all. And secondly, visit a
church. Come on, give me a break. At this point,
I started to think maybe this is a Scientologist.
Seems to me Mike has a problem with the management
of the church. And instead of straightening out
his disagreement but air his difference is on
your program and write a book to make money. Yes,
that sentence makes no sense, but I'm reading
it as written. I gave you more credit than maybe
you deserve if you don't give both sides the
same platform. I have been a Scientologist for
43 years. There it is and has changed my life and
gave me the tools to deal with life successfully.
I've researched all of those tools. They're
all a scam. I hate to tell you, Ray.
Ray goes on to say, Currently and for about
15 years, we don't always agree with the upper
management of the church, but to go to the media
and take your disagreements is irresponsible. So,
David, I challenge you. Go find out on your
own. Either visit a church, find out yourself,
or read a book and see for yourself. I dare
you lol. Sincerely, Ray. I've read I've read
five books about Scientology. I've interviewed
ten Scientologists. I've seen ten documentaries
about Scientology. Have I visited a church? No.
Would the sanitized experience I would get if
I was even allowed to visit a church? Really?
Tell me anything about Scientology? No, but I
understand. Scientologists don't like interviews
critical of Scientology. That question the cult.
Fred wrote in and said, David, I've got to say,
for this to be a progressive show, I have been
shocked that you have not covered the Arkansas
governor debate where Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is going against an MIT Ph.D. Democrat, Chris
Jones, who is the epitome of form over substance
and Pacman show ideals. In many ways, their debate
was today and it will re-air tonight. So, listen,
I hate to kind of like end on a negative note
here. We can't cover every debate that race is
not even close. The Arkansas gubernatorial debate
our governor polling RCP. It's it's like crazy.
Yet Sarah Huckabee Sanders is winning by double
digits. Okay, it is. I get it. Chris Jones is
an interesting candidate. We streamed like 15
debates, mostly close races, races that could
end up making a difference in the balance. We
just can't do everything. We can't do everything.
And that race isn't close. Would I love to be
able to cover more? Sure. But we've got to pick
and choose. So I'm sorry, Fred, but it is not an
indication of any kind of our progressive stature
that we were not able to cover that debate.
All right. Info at David Pakman dot com. Send
in your thoughts for the mailbag. We
have a great bonus show coming up for
you today which you can instantly access
by signing up at join pacman dot com.